brother come in come in Oleg come
in come in
right very close a
month ago it seemed that there are
two and a half thousand people here, that is, all in the
mouth, that is, driving There has been no gas, there
has been no water for 10 months,
everything is broken infrastructure zero
people survive really live mostly in
basements and spend the night exactly in  basements, therefore,
Bender stove stoves are the only
source of heat for people in this
town. Yes, not only in this one.
This is the situation; therefore, we
deliver and try to install as much as possible for
people
as much as possible to provide all the
pipes with all the components so that a
person is not a problem
to come  home In the evening to climb into your
basement tea start
[music]
hole And how many of you are here Masha
people with
all sorts
of May The same schools in Orekhovo I turn
out to be the strength of
all the schools
bombed not by orcs, that of them in Viysky The
horde
came and everything
[music]
on what
[applause]
pensioners cambrid  in retirement, we
pay them by parcel, we accept it, we
send it by parcel. I think work
is still important, we  we can complete
[music]
Oleg
[applause]